let's get back into
hard news i hate it we're having such a
good time and now now we're gonna fight
and now i'm gonna
no i'm gonna make you fight again but
it's okay but i gotta talk about that
muzzle laws there's these laws that have
been introduced in a nur of states
to not talk about critical race theory
now critical race theory i must say to
begin with
i hadn't heard the term probably a year
ago now i hear it every day
i think americans are just starting to
hear it and i think no one knows exactly
what it is
they know it has something to do with
race and it's some kind of a theory
right how would you describe it
and then we'll ask how will you describe
what is critical i will admit that i
read a lot of critical race theory in
law school
so you know the work of derek bell or
john or jean stefan
no one knows but you and six other
people right so
what matters is what is it what is it
practically
it's being taught in schools or some
form of
yes there's there's a certain sort of
crystallized version of it that is
a lot less complex than what critical
race theory actually is but critical
race theory essentially argues
that racism is baked into all the
systems of american society
and that any sort of neutral system is
in fact a
guise for racial power and so the
argument is made by derek bell for
example
that brown versus board of education
this is an argument he made in 1991
that brown versus board of education was
actually a way for the white community
to leverage its own power it wasn't an
attempt to end segregation in public
schools
even things that are reportedly good in
terms of race so long as they uphold
these broader systems things like
capitalism or things like
the meritocracy these things are
actually just guises for power
and so what that boils down to in sort
of practical terms is all disparity
equals discrimination if you can see any
stat
where black people are underperforming
white people this means the system was
set up for the benefit
of white people and that white people
have a duty to tear down these systems
in order to alleviate the racism that's
implicit in those systems when it comes
to
schools what this tends to boil down to
is kids who are white
have experienced privilege because the
system was built for white people
and we have to change the standards
right okay well so malcolm you tell me
your definition
oh i agree with everything he just said
oh oh great
and i appreciate you being honest and
defining of what it's like to be black
american
right that is i mean we're talking about
a system fair
well no i'm just saying i agree with all
of those suppositions because
they are grounded in truth look
when i'm you know and the funny thing is
it's not just african americans right
it's also
the the the scalp act of 1749
where for a hunt 300 modern dollars you
had to cut off the head
or the hair of an indian to prove that
you've got them out of the way so they
could settle
that's a little bit of american history
that people should know about the
chinese exclusion acts of the 1840s
these are things we don't talk about
that's right i mean that's personal
that's not it's not true that people
don't talk about these things we all do
we don't
want them talked about no that's not
true either you wanted to
cancel no malcolm i'm sorry you're lying
that's fine
it is lying i not only have i've
personally talked about many of the
things that you just mentioned
i define critical critical race theory
by citing the actual authors of critical
race theory and you seem to be a pretty
good beneficiary of the meritocracy
because you have merit malcolm so if
you're going to criticize the
meritocracy
there's an outgrowth of white supremacy
then you're going to have to tear down
the system
that you've succeeded in because you
have merit or do you not have merits
you know when my great-great-grandfather
ran away from slavery to join the 111th
u.s colored troops and
fight against the south keeping human
beings
as slaves he didn't think you know what
in 150 years
my great-great-grandson's gonna have to
sit on stage and argue with a guy
who thinks all that's [ __ ] all right
[Applause]
i'm just saying there is no controversy
the controversy that's made up is people
saying that this is being discussed
this is being taught in schools and that
kids should be kept away
that's not true it's not even a real
controversy the fifth largest school
district in america clark county just
decided that they were going to lower
standards with regard to testing because
they wanted to alleviate disparities in
outcomes that is an outgrowth of
critical race theory
can you draw a straight line to it yes
100 because when you say
that the meritocracy is an outgrowth of
white supremacy and then you suggest
that i'm somehow denying that slavery
took place or that your great great
great grandfather was a hero because i'm
saying that i want people tested when
they are in school to see if they are
good at school
and then what you are according to that
was just nonsense
but i think it's also a leap to say that
he thought that was [ __ ] because
that's not what it is i mean we're
talking
are we talking about 2021 are we talking
about 1861
because the point is can we talk about
1861 and 2021 yes we can
and i don't know i don't know who it is
i don't know who's against talking about
history
well i mean i understand that they want
to you know in texas they're talking
about remember having references to the
ku klux klan they're talking about we're
moving i mean come on that's texas
i mean how can you watch forrest gump
without even knowing who nathan bedford
forest is
right i mean these are people who are
historical figures who did bad things
no one is actually saying we want to go
back
and erase everything and restart and
talk to you about these things critical
race theory is a subject because the
republican right has made it a subject
no no no no no
real school organizations are mandating
this course
every democrat in america takes your
perspective and they will and
and they will be shellacked at the polls
roy teshera just wrote a piece the
emerging democrat majority roy share he
just heard a piece about what he called
the fox news fallacy a tendency of
people on the left
to believe that just because fox news
mentioned something it can't be real
the reality is a lot of this stuff is
taught in schools you mean like viruses
well okay well can i can i i'm
now now i'm just i don't know i don't
know i'm just
confused can i just what you're talking
about what people
are experiencing in their lives in their
schools
yeah okay you're right there are states
like from the old confederacy
i think who do want to airbrush history
that's not i think the majority in this
country
if you ask me in critical race theory if
you say does that mean
teach history on varnish i would say yes
then i'm totally for critical race
theory
if you say does it mean acknowledging
that racism persists today
i would say yes teach that
should we have remedial means that's
like affirmative action
there's lots of people who are against
that i'm still for that i still think
when you read the statistics
and i have some of them here blacks earn
40 percent
less 90 less family wealth
high poverty high schools 72 blacks to
31
white lives six years shorter half as
likely to go to college
eight times more incarcerated these are
real statistics
the question is what how do we what do
we do to address them
i th what these are real statistics
i you think we should address them you
think we should address them
right the question is what are we doing
about it
because if ra if critical race theory
means
making children in school fixate on race
i'm not for that
if it makes if it's about collective
guilt
i didn't do anything to your great great
great grandfather
i don't want to be responsible for that
if it's about
you know a toxicity of just from being
born white
uh if it's about dividing everybody into
oppressor and oppressive
oppressed and oppressor i'm not for that
so there are things that
are being taught and are going around
that i'm not for that
if that was critical race there i
wouldn't be for i agree with you and i
don't think that's critical race theory
but it's being okay i think what's
happened here
what's happened here as this this
terminology
sort of like defund the police has been
hijacked and been
framed around the left as that they want
to do all this they want to rip down the
entire social fabric of america and they
want us to be guilty about everything
i want you to teach history i had a lot
of people in the military
hold on i had a lot of people in the
military
senior officers who had to make
life-and-death decisions who were total
morons about the cultures and
institutions right so in
countries we were going into and people
died because of that
i don't need that here if we agree that
history should be taught
why are you defending critical race
theory which is not history did i not
just say a moment ago that i think that
term has been hijacked and that's not
okay so let's say critical race
i'm going to go back and repeat that i
didn't say that okay you
you are literally defending critical
race theory by redefining it as just
teaching history which is a cheap
semantic trick and you know it is this
what you do on your show cause it sucks
ice you know nathan
[Applause]
malcolm i appreciate that but i will i
will i will comfort myself
sleeping on my bed made of money i'm
sure we have an adult i'm sure
i'm sure we have that i'm sure we have
another adult subject to talk about
well how about that andrew cuomo
you